non loin d'arc en ville a fait quand
l'orage a également fait beaucoup de
dégâts en deux ans la population a connu
quatre inondations les habitants
estiment ce matin que les travaux
entrepris pour protéger la ville ne sont
pas assez rapides
reportage à news garder jean nil blanc
rarement l'orage n'aura été aussi
violent comme en témoigne ce document
amateur tournée dans les environs de 10h
hier après midi
plus au sud en seine maritime
la ville de fécamp elle est aussi été
surprises par les eaux la pluie puis
l'orage et enfin cette vague de plus
d'un mètre de haut
il est tombé 30 mm d'eau en moins d'une
heure l'équivalent de 15 jours des
précipitations jusque tard dans la nuit
pompiers des services techniques ont
paré au plus urgent font fait et l'idée
les caves
il y avait une hauteur je sais pas moi
ça représente et peut-être un maître
vers le flou on va un taureau oui c'est
en instaurant une vague
c'est un petit peu affolant quand vous
voyez
nous arriver arriva une rapidité on
attendait absolument rien faire et la
deuxième inondation depuis décembre la
quatrième en deux ans alors ici dans
cette maison
l'accès au garage a été purement et
simplement condamné quelques anciennes
prince ici ici partout où tu sais à
répétition ces nettoyages à répétition
ses angoisses à répétition et ses pertes
à répétition
alors certes il ya les orages mais fait
quand au fond d'une cuvette est très
exposée aux inondations à cela une
réponse les bassins de rétention d'eau
au bout de ce chemin défoncé par la
coulée de boue se trouve la plus
importante de ces retenu trop plein hier
à la déborder la vague est parti d'ici
jusqu'au centre ville
il a plu pendant à peu près un quart
d'heure vingt minutes révèle très
violemment
les chances sont un goûter de paraître
du bassin versant
le bassin est monté très rapidement vu
la violence de la pluie et il est donc
passé en surverse donc il n'a pas assez
d un il est passé en surverse par la
petite sur vers ce qu'on voit là et
ensuite en surface globale pour en fait
permettre de recevoir et ne pas céder
quoi c'est ça le principe du bassin ces
bassins coûte entre 200 et 400 me feront
un investissement énorme pour une petite
collectivité comme ces camps
actuellement il en existe cinq répartis
autour de la ville
mais il faudrait doubler cette capacité
pour protéger fécamp et ses environs un
plan de grands travaux a été lancé la
fin n'est prévue qu'en 2002